now fighting in Ukraine's donbass region
is intensifying the British defense
Ministry says it appears Russia has
taken control of the small salt mining
town of Soledad Ukraine's military has
been fending off attacks near the town
for four days it's near bakmut where
troops on both sides have suffered heavy
losses
well for more on this let's go to
Charles Stratford whose life for us in
Kiev Charles what more can you tell us
about this apparent gain by Russian
forces
what is very difficult as you can
imagine to verify these kind of claims
what we do know though is that solidar
is a huge strategic importance as part
of the wider assault by Russian forces
on the town of Bahamut solidar is around
20 kilometers north east of bakmut a
small mining town it used to have a
population of around 10 000 we've seen
video evidence of fierce battles ongoing
there um certainly the UK defense
Ministry saying they think it's likely
that Russian forces have taken control
of most of that town last night we heard
from president zielinski saying that
Ukrainian forces in his words had one
more time in in solidar again pointing
to the importance of bakmud to the South
we also know though that this town has
been contested for months now largely
it's been hit by heavy artillery from
the Russians but we knew we do know now
that uh according to military analysts
and these intelligence reports that the
fighting seems to be very heavy and in
the streets indeed they've been
Witnesses quoted on some of the agencies
who managed to escape the town
describing having to move back street by
Street as tanks moved in
um interestingly as well there are
reports that heavy contingents of the
Wagner group this private mercenary
group who's a leader of Guinea pregos in
is very close to Vladimir Putin analysts
are saying that the Wagner group are
making up a large number of Russian
forces fighting for for solidar and
again interestingly on the wires there
has been a statement made picked up by
social media or from social media by
previous in he actually saying that the
fighting there in solidar is ongoing as
I say the reason why this is important
is because solidar is to the northeast
of buckmut and we know that there has
been months of fighting for control of
the town of Bahamut the town that has
been given the nickname a meat grinder
we know that Russian forces are to the
east of bakmut
arguably some people are saying actually
in the town in the East and there's also
heavy fighting to the southeast of
Bahamut as they try and push North and
bakmut is important because if Russia
took full control of that town then it
would potentially give them an easier
route to the two largest towns still in
full Ukrainian control in the Donetsk
region the towns of chromatolsk and
slovians can interest in the in recent
days we've seen increasing shelling of
unspecified targets artillery shelling
by the Russians of the town of
crematorsk as well so yeah all
indications would suggest face fighting
for the control of the town of solidar
all part of this plan by the Russians to
take control of bakmut but so far the
ukrainians holding the bag
many thanks Charles Charles Stratford
live in Kiev